is 45 the most honest alive
it's not gonna be
no if he says it's so
yeah donald trump's thinking he's more
truthful
than lincoln
while defending investigations into his
tax affairs at a rally in north carolina
that's a state cat
former president trump reminded us that
he's the most honest human ever created
and i hope he quotes me a friend of mine
smart guy very successful guy a lot of
common sense
a friend of mine
smart guy very successful guy a lot of
common sense he said you know you've
been investigated
for years and years millions and
millions of pages of documents they
found nothing you are the cleanest guy
on earth when you think about it i've
got to be the cleanest sheriff i think
i'm the most honest human being
perhaps that god ever created perhaps
perhaps why is he waffling
and what he said has got to be true
after all he is the most honest human
ever and it's refreshing when a
president pronounces all of his words
at the rally he also talked about how a
republican congress would quote end the
woke war on women and children and
hopefully biden's efforts to smell their
hair
of course trump also discussed the
current president old joe's ears must be
burning but that could be from the
liniment on his hair plugs
but i wonder if you took the five worst
presidents in history and put them
together would they have done the damage
joe biden has done to our country in
just 15 months
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage joe biden has done to our
country in just 15 months
thank you for the clarification joe
what's your response
hey look look i'm not going to get to
play this guy's game in
uh
it to other presidents but i'll put
myself up against any of these guys uh
thomas jefferson washington uh the uh
freddie
boom boom washington and all the sweat
hogs and the uh j
f
k f c
f d r
f k text joe just 3 3
0. look look
america
i said it before it can be summed up in
one word i was walking on a the path
with the xi jin uh
jim uh jiminy cricket and uh you know
the thing about the
uh wish upon a star that's all true man
it is it is
tyrus
he lo i mean
it's true i mean once you once you see
that joe biden is the least transparent
and that's how he got elected he was
like a he's like a halloween costume of
joe biden not a joe biden who would have
ever thought that scarface would end up
being a history piece
i tell the truth even when i lie people
need a bad guy like me yeah and uh
apparently we do because
and he's not he did say perhaps perhaps
yeah so he wasn't being arrogant about
it he was just saying he's heard some
things
by very many people but he's kind of
starting to look like
he was telling the truth right
especially about the hunter biden
situation and the ukraine situation
and you look at all the things and the
russia he's damn yeah he's been right
about all the things that were
supposedly huge distractions china that
took away from his deeds that were good
and the argument was yeah he does the
deeds but his tweets and verb and he
says he's all over the place and
everything is conspiracy
turns out he was pretty much around 95
percent right of the stuff that was
supposedly such a distraction to this
company uh country yeah it was good for
us it was good for company
but and that's amazing to me because
there was so much effort to disprove
that's the truth
he looks better and better in the rear
view mirror you know cat he's obviously
trolling the media
uh who refused to see this as a joke i
mean we all are in on this we all find
it hilarious but there are people that
actually fact check this you can't you
can't be serious he says he's the most
honest person oh my how could he
people are still don't understand this
especially because when he said that
people even there were laughing yes they
understood that he was joking because
obviously the most honest human being is
a baby or george every baby every baby's
honest human being and then everyone
grows up and then they'll all lie we all
have secrets we have passwords on our
phones not because we don't want someone
to make a call on it but because our
phones are full of secrets yes that's
true that's true wow
did you not know that dark turn yeah i
took a dark turn i'm very dark can i
have your password you can have it
no exactly
his phone's full of secrets too
quarry
corey saved me from where i am right now
i'm in a dark place well i'll tell you
something look president trump is one of
the most honest presidents we've ever
had look at what he ran on the campaign
trails it was promises made promises
kept he did look at trade imbalances and
rebalance those he did move our embassy
to jerusalem something that many other
republican presidents had said that
never done he did hold our adversaries
accountable he did hold china
accountable and even did the china phase
one deal which helped our agricultural
sectors so all the things that he
actually said on his campaign trail he
held through he talked about his
campaign being spied upon we saw that to
be true he talked about the hunter biden
laptop which were 567 some odd days the
media tried to cover up it was true so i
actually go ahead and while it was a
joke it came to be fact so i actually
support the president's actually come
out and said that's the funny thing it's
funny because it's kind of true
well see
everybody and he does this all the time
and the media goes crazy
is what the
they're going to hold on to the honest
aspect of it and everybody knows trump
exaggerate
but one thing it is true about him is
that he's authentically him
and
no god he he sees the numbers
over 50 of americans said they were
better off they just wanted him to
change his tone yeah yeah right they
believe with his policies and everything
but he he's going to be him he's not
going to be the people that are a part
of the media or the big washington
politicians
and i i kind of got to respect it you
know it's like
cling to honest or authentic
authenticity
take your pick yeah yeah it is the it's
i go back to the agent or the lawyer
analogy like would you rather have an
agent or a lawyer that when he shows up
everybody hates him because that means
he's doing his job or somebody like joe
biden who shows up and they pat him on
the back let's do lunch they go to the
same charity auctions they go to their
kids go to the same private schools
trump is like no he walks in and
everybody turns their back like because
he's like not them that's the person you
want that's the
nobel peace prize i mean obama got the
nobel peace prize and meanwhile
president trump put together abram's
accord one of the biggest things and got
nothing yeah
great point hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else